hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at precompiled
headers definitely check out that video
you haven't already and today we're
gonna be finally creating a window so
that we can render stuff onto our window
so I was really contemplating when to do
this in this whole game engine series
because I mean technically speaking I
probably would have done a lot of stuff
before I even considered adding the
window if I was just making a game
engine in my own time I was kind of a
software engineer I would make sure that
I had a lot of stuff already done before
I kind of just made the window making
the window and kind of doing all of that
graphic stuff is what a lot of people do
is their first kind of steps as you kind
of learn more though and as you get more
familiar with what kind of a game engine
how game engine is actually
architectured and what that looks like
it becomes apparent that there's so much
more than a window and whilst adding a
window is useful because you can like
render text and display debug
information and visualize things
actually working in your game engine as
well as the fact that you know games
typically render graphics and that's
kind of important once you kind of if
you put that aside there's actually a
lot of stuff to a game engine like the
event system like the application system
like a layer stack system like I don't
know input manages all of that stuff
that actually have acted that actually
has to be done potentially long before
you have a window so I've kind of made
this decision to actually make a window
now though because I feel like a lot of
people are beginning to maybe lose a bit
of interest and I have to kind of in
this whole game engine series I have to
actually remember that I'm not just a
software engineer building a game engine
I'm actually also trying to teach and
also trying to be somewhat entertaining
so that people are actually enjoying
these videos and so because of that
there are kind of compromises that I
make and we talked a lot about this
during the partner hangout by the way if
you guys aren't aware you can support me
on patreon I come for slash the Cherno
and if you pledge 1/7 here you actually
get invited to a partner hangout but we
have fun once a month where we actually
just have a video chat with all the
other partners partner is a tier of
patreon support on my patreon we
actually have a discussion about where
the series is going and how to do things
and this actually came up I think in the
last month partner hangout in November
so um definitely check that out
you're interested but I have to make
compromises because I have to compromise
between entertainment education and
software engineering anyway I've decided
to make a window kind of now I think now
is a good point we at least have logging
and we have events that stuff is like a
must in my opinion before you make a
window because I mean it doesn't really
matter you can make your window first
and then make the other systems but that
your hand-in-hand
you need logging because you need to see
what's happening if things go wrong and
as you're kind of running your window
klass it's nice to be able to insert
logging and like a sessions and stuff we
actually talked about assertions of
loosely today as well but you also want
events because a window is very tightly
tied with events and we're just going to
take a look at actually implementing
kind of a window class today in an
abstract way because remember we want to
support multiple platforms and the
implementation of windows on those other
platforms will actually kind of differ
so we want an abstract representation of
a window which we'll talk about today
and then also you know stuff like events
I think we'll cover in the next episode
a week we can actually hook up our
window system to all the power events
and just have that kind of work
correctly so let's talk about the
technology that we use a little bit so
I'm going to use a library called GL FW
I have an open GL series and I have a
video about GLW which will probably be
more detailed in today's video I'm gonna
assume that you guys kind of know how to
use that GL w is very very simple kind
of cross-platform cross-platform meaning
like Windows Mac Linux I think they
support maybe other platforms as well
but it's just a really easy way to kind
of create a window a window using your
relevant platform API I don't really
want to take too much time to actually
use the win32 API to create a window
just because not what this series is
really about we we might eventually have
to because you know jello W for example
doesn't actually support directx right
we probably we definitely want to
support directx and hazel at some point
because that's my preferred rendering
platform on Windows and it should be
everyone's preferred rendering API on
Windows because it's made by Microsoft
for Windows so obviously it's going to
be better than any other API when you're
running on Windows
that being said I do want to get
something up and running and I think I
mentioned that we're gonna stick to
OpenGL in the beginning just so that we
can get stuff as quickly as possible
so because of that we have kind of a
dilemma so I don't want to waste time
now writing win32 API code but we might
have to in the future and also GL FW
something that's available on multiple
platforms so immediately we kind of have
to think about well where does the
abstraction lie what I've chosen to do
is to implement a window class per
platform now you might be like well hang
on if you're using GL of w isn't the
implementation going to be largely the
same on Windows Mac and Linux well yes
initially it probably will be or it will
be similar maybe there's some slight
differences some stuff that we might
want to add that's on Windows only for
example or that might differ on other
platforms but GL of W wise of course
it's going to be the same because it's a
Jill of W use that abstraction away into
the other kind of platforms so I'm still
going to make a separate window class
per platform however and I think this is
the first time we're actually
abstracting stuff so we'll talk about
that as well however in the future we
might be like you know what job W on
Windows I'm dropping that because we're
actually going to switch to using win32
API because we need to make a DirectX
context know what that I mean we could
modify jail of W potentially to do that
or we could just get the required win32
like H wind handles and stuff like that
and like the device handles the device
context handles from shelf W which it
uses to create the windows window using
the win32 api anyway and then from there
we would have our necessary handles that
we need to actually create a DirectX
context but I haven't decided yet but
the point is there's definitely going to
be a point but we do Windows only
windows creation code and all that stuff
right so we definitely want a Windows
kind of window even though we're using
jelf W which is cross-platform so
hopefully that makes sense
I've also modified I've also forked GL
FW into my own private or put into my
own github repository it's public it's
just the turn of its github book home
slash the turn o /f w we'll use it here
in a minute
I've just added premake to it it's a
really quick pre make file that only
works on Windows for now I'll probably
update that in the future to support
more platforms as well
but they're just an easy way to
integrate Chillicothe with our pre make
built while still having gel FW or the
source code in our visual studio
solution and all of that and then just
link it kind of project wise so that's
what I've done as well um and I think we
can probably talk about just the notion
of platform abstraction and how that
works I'm probably make a video
dedicated to that because today I just
want to get a window up and running and
if I start talking about this it's gonna
end up taking up the whole episode but
essentially what I've done is I made a
platform folder which is for
platform-specific code and then I've
made a Windows folder which is for
Windows code right we'll also have you
know eventually a Mac and Linux folder
and maybe if we support mobile platforms
you know Android iOS that kind of stuff
and in the platform folder will also lie
our rendering API specific codes such as
locum jail DirectX welcome metal that
kind of stuff will also have its own
fault of that um we might even have a
POSIX folder that's just kind of you
know Mac and Linux related in that and
Android related kind of code if it ends
up being the same but that's kind of the
idea that's all you need to know about
Homestar abstraction now let's go ahead
and add the gfw repository that I've
[ __ ] as a sub-module now so that we
can actually get it into our project
okay so what I have here is as you can
see the channel is /lw I've just forked
it from GL FW um a while ago I think
because you can see it's 11 commits
behind master but it's just forked from
shelf to view master and then what we'll
have done is I've added this and there's
actually 28 days ago Wow four weeks ago
I added this premix so you can see how
much how far ahead the the hazeled dev
repository is which patrons get access
to because I did this actually like four
weeks ago but anyway um it's per make
five lower file very simple right it's
45 lines of code all this does is just
for Windows essentially for now the
indentation I think is a bit wrong but
anyway um this stuff doesn't even work
and this needs to be updated to the
latest and there's a few things that
need to be done actually I thought I
pushed that by I didn't
so yeah an indentation is horrible but
anyway you can see includes all the
relevant files here under filter windows
these are all the platform
platform-independent files is the
windows only files and then it's got
defines as well and all that stuff
really simple stuff nothing really to it
we're going to clone this as a sub
module because this includes our pre
make file as well as all of GL fw so on
a command prompt in c dev hazel which is
our kind of repository root I'm just
going to type in get sub module add I
want to add this job W sub module and I
want to add it to hazel slash vendor /lw
ok and it's going to clone this whole
repository into that directory and then
if we kind of boot this up we should see
inside vendor we now have GL fw ok and
that has our version of jail shelf w
along with that pre make file so now
what we want to do is actually add it to
our pre make file and I've already done
that so I will just show you the diff in
fact we'll just do a git will do a
difficult idea ok so this is all of it
let's look at the pre make 5 files so
this is what I've done to the pre make
file I actually ended up creating
basically a struct a lower table which
is going to be a list of include
directories that we have that aren't
ours now these are important because we
want to obviously have gel fwz include
directory you know in Hazel's so that we
can just use gel fw /lw 3 - 4 which will
have to include so I'm setting a
compiler include directory but I've just
put it into its own kind of struct here
into its own table because this will
grow obviously to include each
dependency this include here actually
includes that pre make file that we have
so this pre make file you know we just
looked at this this directory is hazel
Vantage lfw ok I'm including this which
what this will do is include that pre
make 5 file into here so basically this
is almost like a c++ style include where
this if we look at this individual
studio this kind of gets copied and
pasted into our pre make 5 file right so
inside our pre make file we now have
another project called GL fw you can see
this does not have workspace or anything
like that it doesn't have
space job W it doesn't have a solution
it's just a project just an additional
project which compiles as a static
library outputs into the same directory
and it just includes a bunch of files
okay that's all it is we've just added
now added another project and then the
important thing is what we have that
project we're actually going to link it
right to our hazel project so hazel is
now dependent on GFW hazel is a shared
library meaning if the dll file so of
course we can just include a static
library into it right or linked rather a
static library into it we need to fix up
this in the indentation I did not know
it was so bad this is what happens when
you don't let's look at this for a
minute and let's go to view where is
this I think it's in view no edit
advanced and view whitespace just so we
can see what on earth is going on so you
can see this is tabs and this is space
as that's why it's messing up so I'm
just going to convert all of this to
spaces and this should make everything a
lot better because clearly we're mostly
using spaces in this file I think that's
not this is a tab as well okay and so is
this stuff so it's quite useful for if
you want to fix stuff up like this I can
we can get rid of that okay brilliant
then hopefully refresh this everything
should be better it's not though this is
on digital well if it's made a temporary
for some reason so that's just um rerun
diff tool and we should see this is now
perfect but it's clearly not it's the
right file Ison shelf W whoops okay so
we fixed the show of w1 let's fix our
one as well because this is apparently a
mess oh wow so this is mostly tabs I see
yeah this is little tabs
[Music]
okay this is spaces oh wow okay we need
to really stick to tabs all spaces and
not use both because this is a bit of a
drag anyway I think that should be good
we've got tabs everywhere now okay so
does that fix it don't we have to
restart this again because it is in a
temporary directory and there we go good
it's good now okay so back back to this
so we're linking Jeff W which is that
project that we've just included
okay now this include directory just
needs to get at it as a compiler include
directory which is what we've done here
now included directories in our include
directories we've added include
directory don't you love w which means
that Hazel Vantage of W include is now a
compiler include directory okay and
that's all the changes that I've made so
literally include that pre make file and
then just set the include directory and
link we're also linking OpenGL 32 live
because we need that that's all that
I've done okay now let's take a look at
some of the new files that I've added
actually well first thing let's just run
Premack because I haven't even ran
pretty much yet so we'll do generate
projects and then her voice will do dual
that you can see is generate that she'll
be project if we go back to visual
studio reload this the solution we
should see gel of w here then you should
see that hazel actually references gel
of w okay beautiful
let's try and compile that in debug x64
hopefully this compiles successfully I
haven't actually done this ok so there's
some unknown options I'll clean that up
in the gel if W thing I don't know this
is just trying to use c11 but obviously
this is not for fiddle to use compiler
because of the way that it's linking
this is more or less for probably clang
or JCC would probably both accept this
but um obviously there's a different
syntax for command-line arguments in the
MS they say compiler anyway one
succeeded is just ignoring those that's
fine and we've now built gel double you
can see how easy that was so I love
premake because it's so nice and easy to
use
ok so next step let's take a look at
some of the window classes that I've
made so inside hazel just inside hazel
you see there's a platform folder as
well but inside hey
all itself I have this window class now
and this is an abstract representation
of a window okay so this is platform
independent this is what our application
uses haven't written it yet I'll write
it in front of you guys application it
hasn't been modified yet but we're
basically gonna use this window okay and
you can see what it has now it's got an
event callback function which we'll talk
about in the next episode I did a
virtual destructor and then it's mostly
as you can see pretty much it's it's all
actually just an interface right
all of these are pure virtual methods
there's no data in this class at all and
there's no functions in this class at
all just pure virtual stuff right
because this has to be implemented per
platform so I've just made an interface
okay a desktop system of course because
mobile apps for example don't really
have a window they more or less have it
like a surface okay so that's that okay
kind of basic not much will add stuff to
it as we go but that's just what it is
and then this I just have some basically
window properties which you can specify
over here now because this is kind of
platform independent this we have this
create function which actually has to be
implemented per platform so this is not
there's no window door CPP file there's
just a window file just a header file
and then this gets implemented per
platform because obviously this creation
function should return for example
windows window if we're compiling on
Windows or Mac Windows or Linux window
or whatever we decide to call it
depending on what platform were actually
compiling on there's no need for example
have a platform independent one which
you know it has a switch statement which
includes and it doesn't it this is all
decided at compile time anyway we're not
gonna be compiling mac code on windows
or vice versa
property is titled width height that's
all we got now default valid default
parameters here as well hazel engine is
the the default title if you don't
specify one and then 1280 by 720 is the
default width and height and then you
can see we have if you don't specify
where's properties it creates the
default which is this okay that's that
now inside platform inside windows we
have windows winter and
the CPP file as well okay this is pretty
simple this is just an implementation of
everything okay so some of this stuff
actually it really should be marked as
override I don't know why it's not so
let's see what it actually inherits so
vsync and then event callback with
height and on update so that's all set I
just missed these two apparently okay
yeah okay so the way that this is
primarily um implemented is we have a
struct of window data you'll see why we
have this because we need to pass it
into jelf W but that's more or less for
events which we'll talk about next time
anyway
but basically this is where we store all
of our actual data that might be
requested by jello W during about
callbacks and then we just have a struct
this way we can pass just the struct to
gel of W as like custom user data and we
don't have to pass this entire class not
that it matters too much but this just
keeps all of our kind of window specific
data grouped nicely here which I claim
which I kind of like we have in it and
shutdown which is two kind of functions
that we've created on update we'll just
kind of should just update shelf W swap
the buffers pull the input events all
that kind of stuff it should be run like
once the frame and called from our
application we'll call that in a minute
everything else I think is pretty
straightforward let's pop over to the
implementation so here's the
implementation of that creation function
that we had in Windows and window we had
this create function was it this
actually gets implemented in a platform
specific file so in this case it's
implemented you can seize window create
not windows window create just window
create and returns a new windows window
ok that's it pretty simple it's just
returns a pointer okay will store this
pointer in probably a unique pointer in
the actual application class okay so in
the init in the initialization
destructor does nothing for now this
just causing it we the reason I haven't
done anything in the destructor yet is
because we not don't necessarily need to
we can destroy the window actually I
think Jill if W destroy window we should
do that in shutdown let's just add that
right now shut down we can do that but
we don't want to necessarily shut down
jail fw because we might we might need
it like we might have more than one
window that's also why I have this
static here because we only want to
initialize jail w once when we
initialize our window but we might
create multiple windows so yeah but if
it's not a if it hasn't been initialized
yet we'll initialize it so this is
that's essentially what in it does when
we create this window it calls the
constructor which calls in it sets up
all of our data based on the properties
log some stuff that we might want to see
initializes gel-v if it hasn't yet and
then let's talk about this chorus cuz
that's new inside core RH I've added
assertions if we enabled them okay we
should add that to the pre make file for
debug probably probably not released
what this does is basically it says it
checks a certain condition and then logs
a message if it fails and also its
windows only for now just cause debug
break which basically just is like in
setting a breakpoint at that line of
code so that it just breaks the debugger
on this actual line of code okay so that
if an assertion fails we can see what
has gone wrong okay so for example in
this case we're using it here to check
to see if this has worked out so if this
is something that gets removed in run
time sorry in like release builds for
example or distribution builds that's
why I didn't write this code like this
for example because if that happened and
gelled up you would not be initialized
at all interlaced fields which is not
what we want we still want it to be
initialized but we're just checking the
condition only in India bug builds we
might add something called verify
instead of assert which basically is the
same as an assert except it doesn't
strip the condition so it basically does
that instead the reason is that this can
because this compiles to nothing at all
in like certain configurations if enable
of sessions is off we can do we can run
functions that we wouldn't otherwise run
at all just to verify stuff so it's
quite useful amen
just something that we'll be using a lot
of I love using them just a quick way to
verify that your state is correct and
you don't have to worry about wasting
performance when you do that because
they get stripped from release builds we
gel W create window again that sure
little that GLW video and my opengl
scenarios will probably explain more
about this but we basically just create
gel up W window make the contacts
current and set a window user pointer
now this is something that we'll use in
our event callbacks for M data because
when we but the way the GL Toby works is
that we just set certain event callbacks
for example jello W set you know Kiki
callback and this is just a callback
function that we specify that will get
called whenever we press a key this
means that we are passing this struct of
data or appointed to this struct of data
into that callback function so that we
can for example be like I can call that
event callback function if if a key is
pressed or if the window size changes I
can set this width and height and also
call the callback so that's kind of what
we said this form and then vsync we've
just set it true because there's no
reason really for it to be off shutdown
destroys the window we just added that
now update will just pull the events and
swap the buffers and then we have a set
of async function which if if we decide
to enable vsync access these [ __ ]
interval to one this isn't actually
necessarily have to be one one just
means it'll wait for like one frame to
be called one frame to be rendered
before it starts like the next thing
whereas zero means nothing so that's
what we've done for now again I imagine
once we replaces we with the win32 card
will actually might do something a bit
different but that's just a basic
implementation facing and then we keep
track of whether or not it's enabled
because we can't actually retrieve that
data from Java over here and then we
just we haven't and is facing function
which returns for the wrong that is
switched on okay that's it that's our
window really simple stuff let's add
this to our our application now so what
I'm going to do is inside application
again this is platform independent
I'm going to create a unique pointer
which is going to hold an instance of
the window class unique because
obviously only this class owns it this
will be just window garage so we have a
unique pointer of window and then all we
do is in the constructor we'll set this
to be want to make unique or anything
it's just gonna be window create window
or window window create and we'll
specify probably no properties now
because this is an explicit constructor
we actually have to type unique pointer
here and then do window create like that
crater okay cool so we've got that we've
got our unique pointer means we don't
have to delete the window ourselves when
the application terminates we
application obviously is kind of a
singleton meaning we only have one
application for our entire application
so um this is definitely fine okay we'll
get rid of all this kind of event
testing for now and then inside here I'm
actually going to make a bull here
called running which will probably set
to true to begin with we can just
initialize it here so while this is
running by going to update our window by
calling em window on update and I mean
we could just chuck in some OpenGL card
here to test it in a minute but that
should be all we need to do really
because window create will call the
constructor which will call init which
will actually create an initializer self
W and create our windows they actually
should be good so if we hit f5 or the
play button here just to actually debug
our code we'll see what happens and this
is obviously building and linking jail W
for the first time so hopefully
everything works out okay check that out
so we have hazel engine here over here
it says that we've created a window
which is our hazel engine I might just
get rid of this app hollow maybe we can
keep it that because it's testing um
client side logging but yeah credit
window hazel engine 1280 by 720 you can
see it's there we can't close it or
anything because we're not handling
events yet there will be the next
episode but we have the
awesome and we should also have an
OpenGL context so what we should be able
to do is for now I'll be naughty and
include Chell w3 in this file and I'll
just do something like GL clear color um
one zero one one which is pink or
magenta and then we'll just call jail
clear on the color buffer bit okay let's
see if this works we should get a pink
window here awesome
there you go okay so we have now a
window finally and an OpenGL context no
events yet so we wanna the next step
kind of of where I would go from here is
to actually make it so that key events
and mouse events and window events like
closing and resizing and all of that fun
stuff is actually propagated to this
application class so essentially what we
want to have is a function here which is
like on event right and on event
function which one we call which we will
kind of call from the window class but
we obviously don't want the window class
to be aware of application at all should
be completely modular and kind of out to
the side should not depend on
application at all which is why we have
a set event callback function which will
just kind of call from the application
to notify the window hey all the events
please call them back into here and then
we can propagate them to all about
layers and that is how this engine will
basically deal with events of any kind
including window events so next time
we'll implement that that I'm really
excited about that I think if we just
look at the diff I don't think I've
missed anything other stuff I did I
modified the PCH oh yeah I added the log
to the PCH file because log is not going
to change and this is something we want
in pretty much every file and chord on H
I add the sessions as I mentioned
earlier and that's it so I didn't modify
much the big thing was obviously she
loved W so that is it okay so that's our
window class I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did you can hit that
like button you can also help support
this series by got a patron come forward
slash the churner huge thank you as
always to all the patrons that make this
series possible next time we're going to
be implementing advance
into our window class I'm really excited
about that because that'll be cool we'll
actually be able to like move the mouse
and see what the mouse position is and
then from there we can probably get on
to rendering graphics of some kind and
probably before that though setting up
like a layer system and we can get on to
more kind of engine architecture kind of
stuff as well but now we have a graphics
context where we can draw things on to
so we'll probably add items go into that
pretty quickly so that we can actually
start seeing like you know a visual
representation of of things and actually
just have more data available to us
there might be a bit awkward or just
anointing to log so yeah that's the plan
hope you guys are excited for that I'll
see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]